[Music]
we gotta have you reach in here and pick
a question out of our Santa hats okay
Santa have you got a good one I hope so
- who do you plan to kiss under the
mistletoe this season you have a new man
right yeah I'm gonna be kissing hands
yeah yeah I love how glowy and smiley
you just got yeah yeah about him that
you love the most
he's just amazing like treats me honey
is it kind of nice to be on your own a
little bit and doing all these features
aside with harmony obviously of so much
love for them but is it nice to explore
that Wow yeah all of us are exploring it
right now you know we're at such an
amazing place harmoniously with each
other with communication and just like
support for one another that like you
know we've grown so much over the past
year even and and I love genuinely being
able to explore myself and know that my
girls are like there for me and it's the
same for all of us so it's really cool
because we're just kind of branching out
to creatively discover ourselves cuz we
never really got an opportunity to do
that since we started this one we're
like six I was 16 when I started you
know so put you guys together so you
have to kind of conform to like what fit
harmony would be when essentially not
any one of us is that on our own you
know what I mean so it's cool to be able
to give each other that space to really
explore ourselves individually and grown